so matter is just what conscious in
their life
looks like from a perspective if i look
in the mirror
i see my conscious inner life presenting
itself to me in the form of an image
in the mirror if i look at somebody
else's brain on their brain scanner
the images i will see on the monitor of
the brain scanner are what the inner
life of that person the conscious in
their life of that person
will be looking like from my perspective
so i would even define matter as what
experiential states look like
from a perspective and is there
something beyond matter of course
there are other experiential states that
are not directly translatable into
matter like
our endogenous feelings our emotions uh
even some of our abstract thoughts uh
what we call matter is what presents
itself on the screen of perception
in a sense it is perception but there
are more experiential states than just
perceptual states if i lock you up in an
ideal sensory deprivation chamber
and you can't hear see dutch smell
anything you will still
have experiential states you will still
you still have experiential states like
desire
fear thoughts
emotions of every kind so matter is one
part of the puzzle and it's certainly
reconcilable with the
idealism well i mentioned earlier i
think matter is just what inner
experience looks like from a perspective
from across a dissociative boundary and
i think the dissociative boundary
that that defines us as individuals
uh presents itself in perception as the
skin the eyes or
our sensory organs this is the boundary
of
the this dissociative process in
universal mind that we call ourselves
if you understand this you will
immediately come to the conclusion that
what is really out there
is not physical it is mental and
physicality
is relative to mentality yeah
that's how physicality arrives from an
interaction between two segments of mind
at least two
um physicality is relative to mentality
that's what quantum mechanics seems to
be
suggesting and the mentality part i
added because i think it's inevitable
it's the only other thing we know of
next to physicality
but quantum mechanics seems to be
telling us quite unambiguously
especially after a superb experiment in
2018 that sort of closed all loopholes
that physicality is relative relative to
what i would say it's relative to
mentality
so insofar as each person
is a observer a different observer with
a unique perspective
then your physical world is
fundamentally different from my physical
world
because my physical world is relative to
me and i'm taking a different
perspective
so we all inhabit different physical
worlds and more physical worlds
bear with me don't misunderstand me yet
i i have to complete this thought
uh but my personal intuition about it is
that we
are the same subject in different
timelines interacting with it with
itself across those timelines
if that is conceivable at all yeah
so perhaps it is doing that through us
perhaps we are
those eyes that turn back and look
back at the existence and said oh this
is what's happening
this is what's going on maybe the this
is this uh
universal uh metacognition conscious
metacognition
and we are just the beginning someone's
opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host alan sakhyan
i'm super pumped for this episode we're
gonna be talking about
all things metaphysical idealism
we have dr bernardo castro joining us on
the show hi bernardo
hey there good to be here thanks so much
for coming on the program
i'm so pumped for this i have been
in taking all of what you've been
teaching about and i think it's been
super refreshing for getting us to think
more deeply about what is the true
nature of reality
um and that's just such a this is a
fundamental
um and for those who don't know
bernardo's background he's a nine-time
author philosopher of ontology in mind
an ai and reconfigurable computing
scientist
leading the modern renaissance of
metaphysical idealism the notion that
reality is essentially
experiential and you can find his links
in the bio below to his website
bernardocastrip.com
that has links to his books his papers
his essays also
social media profiles so check that out
all right bernardo i mentioned this in
the intro
obviously this is the most first
principled
question that we must not only ask
ourselves as adults but
even inspire children at the youngest
ages to
have deep inquiry into metaphysics the
nature of reality ontology the nature of
being
um the what's the nature of
consciousness
and so yeah this is this is the most
first principle
and i really appreciate how the
the push for idealism was very important
it was the first sort of
ideas about that reality is
inextricably uh connected to our
experience
and i think that that's that was super
important and awakening i like your
phrase
omnis rest anonymous est everything is
mined
and my favorite latin logo
your favorite latin logo on on the site
as well
on your twitter as well yes yes and you
in
a good way to explain that is also all
events facts and
causes are soul spirit and feelings
that would be the broad translation of
the latino
yes now i i
i really want to see if there's a way
to harmonize
the idea of the single reality whose
nature is consciousness
with the idea of the
so-called material but
evolution specifically the fact that
there has been an
evolutionary process to get us
um to this point so what
how do you um bring the topics
together of the fact there has been this
evolutionary process
for the um knowing
to be enabled well can we reconcile
idealism with matter
well there is this thing out there
and even in us that we call matter right
there can be a dispute about
what is it exactly how do we
conceptualize it
what true statements can we can we make
about it and what
false statements but there is this thing
we see
smell touch that that's undeniable so if
idealism cannot
be reconcilable with that it's just
plain wrong right because
there is this thing out there um i think
it's completely reconcilable because you
see
um we only know matter insofar as we
experience it
if there is something out there that
nobody ever has experienced it might as
well not exist
it becomes just a conceptual inferential
reality it doesn't have any
any true existence what idealism would
say is that
what we call matter is what conscious
inner life looks like from a certain
perspective
to be more specific i would say from
across a dissociative boundary but then
you start getting into the details
so matter is just what conscious in
their life looks like
from a perspective if i look in the
mirror i see
my conscious inner life presenting
itself to me in the form of an image
in the mirror if i look at somebody
else's brain on their brain scanner
the images i will see on the monitor of
the brain scanner are what the inner
life of that person the conscious in
their life of that person
will be looking like from my perspective
so i would even define matter as what
experiential states look like
from a perspective and is there
something beyond matter of course
there are other experiential states that
are not directly translatable into
matter like
our endogenous feelings our emotions uh
even some of our abstract thoughts uh
what we call matter is what
presents itself on the screen of
perception in a sense it is
perception but there are more
experiential states than just perceptual
states if i lock you up in an ideal
sensory deprivation chamber
and you can't hear see touch smell
anything you will still
have experiential states you will still
you still have experiential states like
desire
fear thoughts
emotions of every kind so matter is one
part of the puzzle and it certainly
reconcilable with the
idealism oh sorry i gave you an extended
the answer i forgot the second part of
your question
with evolution we have very very good
reasons
to infer that the organization
of living organisms has evolved not only
that even the universe has evolved
it started as a fairly uniform
um framework so to say and then because
of quantum fluctuations and gravity
being applicable to those quantum
fluctuations
it started differentiating itself and
formed you know eventually you know
matter and stars and planets and moons
and
life we have plenty of evidence to
indicate that and i also don't think
any of that is is incompatible with
idealism on the contrary it's even it
even substantiates idealism because
even if everything is consciousness it's
not only your or my
consciousness alone it's a trans
personal consciousness so to say
especially unbound
so we have to account for how individual
private consciousness has arisen within
this transpersonal background and that's
evolution right there um
okay so
out of the
which you've called the like a cosmic
consciousness or other people call an
infinite consciousness
there is a and there is an
a private consciousness as instead of an
individual
um consciousness that that forms and i
really like how
uh rupert spyro has talked about this
idea of the perforation
and like the more that you preferate uh
the
the this circle of the individual or the
private consciousness the more that you
truly feel
like you are and sri aurobindo has
talked about the simultaneity
being a key of life can you
simultaneously be an individual
be the universal and the transcendent at
the same time
i think that's a really beautiful way to
also
put it i like i like how yeah i i'm
i totally vibe on the idea that these
are absolutely compatible things
i think you know in sri aurobindo also
said that one of the main keys to life
is to just never cut life into two
and if you if you do that if you always
keep it at one
every time you try and break these
concepts into this materialism versus
idealism and
and like you try and like consciousness
only versus materials it's just it's
just this idea of like breaking it up
and trying to like
um but i liked your point about sensory
deprivation i think that's an
interesting one so even if i'm
because especially for those that have
been in sensory deprivation tanks i
think
that's extremely salient because if you
have been in them
you know that it it's just
it it really in a sense it also kind of
feels like the womb
and i think that's really beautiful but
and occasionally sure you can maybe hear
like a little bit of the
warm water like slosh against uh the
side
but really you're you're there
completely sensory deprived and
if you don't have a good job of taming
the the elephant i mean the elephant
is you know can be on cocaine and just
your mind the elephant monkey mind just
you know
and so if you yeah and so that's the
idea that you still
get some sort of bubbles of experience
uh even during a complete sensory
deprivation i would say it's the prime
directive of mind
its prime directive is not to be quiet
it is to generate experiences and digest
experiences and then deceive itself
because if there is no deception at some
level of reality
then everything just poof goes out of
existence
so reality is fundamentally dependent
on a certain level of self-deception i'm
not saying that it's personal only there
could be something transpersonal behind
it
but it's the nature of mind your things
up and deceive itself in the process
so when you are in a sensor deprivation
chamber you may feel very quiet in the
beginning
but wait a little longer and you start
seeing that it's almost impossible
to stop that that dynamism that dynamic
activity of mind
to produce images produce thoughts
produce narratives and then deceive
itself
get get gets all tied up in its own
narrative
it's it's the nature of the beast yeah
bernard i'm so interested to hear your
take on this you
hinted at it in this last segment
it's this idea that there is a
there's a there's a list in a sense of
there's like a catalog
of biometric correlates to
phenom phenomenological states of
experience
i really like this a lot and actually i
think
the more that we collectively invest
into science
identifying these biomarkers and
especially at the
building better tools to understand the
biometrics
everything from eeg and fmri to ekg
to microbiome so all over and then
taking that readout and then being able
to provide
like a artificial general intelligence
health corpus be able to or ai coach can
just
you know provide these in these
feedbacks these insights into
you know you your heart rate variability
is
super low right now you are stressed
and like what's the what's the
interaction that
you know maybe going to the pool or
going in a walk right or whatever it may
be
doing some motion um so
how do you you mentioned this earlier
about this idea that like
if we had the biometric correlate of
your
phenomenological state we could in a
sense have like
a telescopic or microscopic idea
of what that is so tell us about your
your reasoning process around that
well i mentioned earlier i think matter
is just what inner experience looks like
from a perspective from across a
dissociative boundary and i think the
dissociative boundary
that that defines us as individuals
uh presents itself in perception as the
skin the eyes or
our sensory organs this this is the
boundary of
the this dissociative process in
universal mind that we call ourselves
so if matter is that uh
what is what experience looks like from
across a dissociative boundary then the
matter of the brain is no exception
neither is the matter of the rest of the
universe but let's talk about the brain
if brain activity is what our normal
individual mentation
looks like from across a perspective of
course there will be correlations there
will be lots of correlations
i would go further and say and suggest
that
we could even come up with interventions
in our
patterns of brain activity that could
lead us to certain
in desirable inner states
do we know that psychoactive substances
from alcohol to psychedelics
they intervene with the matter in our
brain
and they lead us to other experiential
states i would say that
the psychedelic the alcohol or the scalp
of a neurosurgeon when he's digging into
your brain
this is all material therefore these two
are images of transpersonal conscious
processes the scalpel is what a
transpersonal conscious process looks
like
and it goes across your dissociative
boundary interferes with your dissociate
dissociated
individual experiential states what it
looks like is a scalpel cutting in your
brain
or a pill being digested and flooding
your brain with a psychoactive substance
that one mental process influences
another is trivial our emotions
influence our thoughts they are
different but they influence one another
so by the same token a scalpel or drug
can influence our inner states
both our images our brain and that scalp
when the drug
are images of mental processes so
if we can decode the neuro correlates of
meta consciousness or metacognitive
awareness which
which is what i think they are we can
even
find ways to intervene into our brain
activity and
force desirable experiential states by
disrupting ordinary brain activity
in just the right way i think it is
possible to develop this technology and
i would look forward to using it
yes yes oh okay this
this uh this bits gonna it's getting
very interesting so
i loved the focus there on especially on
entheogens and i love that word because
it's about unleashing the divine within
um and it's without a doubt that
there is a super highly correlative
experience experiment with uh taking a
substance that late an antiogen and then
having a psychoactive experience that in
a sense um
could incrementally awaken
and enlighten and so this is where i
want to take this segment now
um ultimately we're
talking about this idea of some sort of
like an artificial general intelligence
that's constantly taking in all of the
sensor data like you have
like today we have jets that have
hundreds of sensors that constantly
monitor everything but like what
our body goes to the doctor one time a
year it's a joke
so that so the idea is that if if we're
constantly analyzing that stream of
sensor data from our body
and then we gave this idea earlier that
there's even something as simple as an
intervention for
for for stress maybe you go out walk on
a walk etc
but there's even deeper interventions
which you were
hinting at the idea that could it be
possible
to have a deeper understanding of a
correlate of specifically enlightenment
or
awakening something that is so
causeless joy and imperturbable peace
that is the
essence of what it would be across brain
across
heart across gut and then and then do
our best to nudge
our society in that direction how does
that resonate
i don't see any fundamental reason why
that shouldn't
be possible i could imagine
that under different circumstances it
could be impossible you could speculate
that maybe
our brain activity is not the complete
image of what's happening in our mind
it's a partial image
so by intervening in it you're not
intervening in a large segment that may
be relevant so you could speculate about
that
i don't see a reason to think that um
i think measurable brain activity
at least measurable in principle there
is activity in the deeper areas of the
brain that today is very hard to measure
with
proper spatial and temporal resolution
but i'm talking about what is possible
in principle um
i think we can in principle measure
everything
that plays a role in our mental states
and
it should be possible if we cared to
invest and
if we care to develop the technology and
do the research necessary
to stimulate mental states that are
conducive to enlightenment or which may
be
our enlightenment we know anecdotally
that
many a psychedelic traveler traveler
has maybe by sheer luck or chance
arrived at the mental states that they
described as
unmistakingly enlightened
you can't do that every time you can't
choose that that's where it's going to
take you psychedelic trips are
very noisy unpredictable they they mix
profound truths
with with profound delusions so it's
very hard to make sense of that we don't
have any control of that
but if we could develop a technology to
control it better at the right
resolution i don't see
any reason why this shouldn't be
possible yeah
yeah there's and that's
this idea of one these interventions
on the awakening or enlightenment
trajectory is
one sort of idea in in a sense they're
they're they're interconnected with
these other ones but just some general
other ones where like
okay you're having you know some back
pain that we're getting an idea about
like get up and go on that walk or go
swim
um another idea okay we're sensing some
you know some ghrelin you
you you you're having this active
sensation happen
for you to want to eat and so but you
want to fast today
so what is the intervention that could
happen today to help you
um fast and so what's your north star if
your if your idea is that you want to
become
a deeper philosopher of mind or if you
want to become a better artist
or scientist or spiritual leader
whatever you want to become what are
those
interventions that can help you achieve
that north star yeah
there is a technology we call it a
transcranial magnetic stimulation
the name is a little bit misleading
because it may be the opposite of
stimulation it may actually
dampen down brain activity it has
beautiful spatial resolution it's
basically an electromagnetic beam that
goes across your skull
and messes up with the activity of your
neurons in
in the desired way and that's very
promising the problem is that it doesn't
have
much penetration so you can activate
or deactivate superficial areas of the
neocortex but you can't go
much deeper but that's an avenue of of
r d and research and development that we
could pursue to achieve exactly what you
what you're
hinting at yeah that's that's a crucial
one and uh
we've heard the analogies of it being
like uh
like a a stadium or an arena and like
you're just like outside the stadium or
the arena trying to like
understand what's happening on the field
and just by like the bear
the bare noise on the yeah yeah fair
analysis
and the tools that's why it's so
important to build better tools because
the better
tools enable more edge pushing
to happen all right
and it does seem like it's slowly going
in the direction of
an idea of like a service to self like a
more of a self-dealing ego driven
uh mentality of of just survival and
reproduction
um towards something that is more of an
enlightened
awakened service to other consciousness
um do you feel that
i in my optimistic moments yeah
uh the rest of the time
you know we we've taken such an an
individualistic
turn after the 60s especially in the 80s
and from then onwards
um that it's hard sometimes to
to stay positive but there are some
bright lights there are things happening
today that would be unthinkable
not a long time ago for instance
because of the the benign influence of
non-dualism in the west
which picked up steam really this
century
it started already back in the new age
movement new thought but it really
picked up steen
this century we now have a language
to talk about transpersonal mental
states
non-duo states before we didn't even
have
the language the collection that's so
yeah the lexicon the two
the conceptual toolset to even talk
about that to say
something coherent about it and and that
has led to some disasters i mean
there was a book written about famous
western philosopher
arthur schopenhauer there's a book
written about him in 1994
by uh supposedly expert
on his writings and philosophy and this
guy had the temerity of
criticized schopenhauer but in doing
that criticism
the only thing he revealed was his utter
inability to comprehend schopenhauer's
non-dual ideas his non-dual philosophy
and why did that happen because you know
i'm being kind to this professor now
because in 1994 we didn't have the
language the conceptual tool set
to even not only to understand but to
talk about
what that guy was trying to hint at he
had to develop his own language which
in a way led to disaster because nobody
really understood what he was talking
about
but now we can understand now i can
write a book talking about these things
and and people share the dictionary with
me they know what i'm
hinting at so that's very optimistic
that's a good sign that things are going
the right way i try to remember this
every day
yeah yeah i i'm so happy you brought
that up the more
that we drive a novel lexicon
that is very
clearly the essence of where our north
star is on our civilizational and
individual trajectories
that's when it makes it more and more
clear for us to share that
corpus like you were indicating that's
so so critical and share that vision
you mentioned schopenhauer which is
excellent
um i feel like the idea
of nothing more fundamental than the
will
the inner nature of everything i love
that one i love
the one eye of the world that looks out
from every creature
i love that one as well so
you know given given the case of
schopenhauer and yourself i mean
we now have significantly more
than 100 years ago had especially
thousands of years ago for talking like
the vedic rishis and stuff
we have significantly more access
um especially under our revelation of
quantum mechanics and whatnot it's just
giving us
more and more access to what we believe
is that nature of reality so
let's talk about this you've written
about this quite a bit now i
find this subject to be
really deeply interrelated between
consciousness and physics in the sense
that this is about
um the bottom up pan psychism and
cosmopsychism
that's that's a that's occurring a
fundamental consciousness as a
universe-wide
field and that
um is is
would it would it be fair to say that
there's
a there's some sort of an
abstract mathematics that are happening
you know infinitely far away and that
it's emerging
it's emerging an illusory holographic
space time i think
just just on a point of terminology yes
you alluded to bottom up
and psychism but you really meant
cosmopsychism uh
bottom up and psychism also called
constitutive pansychism what they would
say is that
every elementary subatomic particle is
conscious but there is no universal
consciousness
there are only gazillions of little tiny
microscopic
consciousnesses i think that's an
untenable view the only technical view
is the opposite there is only one cosmic
subject
and individual subjectivity is an
illusion which is the view i subscribe
to that would be a form of
cosmos psychism now the mathematics
well ellen i think mathematics is how we
describe
things um the fact
that mathematical truths which are so
intuitive to us
so intuitive that it's like it's
self-evidence to us it has to be true
right two plus two
is 4 almost by definition and there are
a number of much more subtle
nuanced mathematical truths that we
are absolutely sure are correct and and
this
psychological intuition happens to apply
perfectly to the dynamics of the world
out there i mean this in itself is
extraordinary under materialistic
metaphysics because there is no
reasoning principle why
our axiomatic rules of thought
should be the rules according to which
the world out there
evolves and moves under idealism
it's not a problem because it's a mind
out there as well
actually it's the same mind and the
division is the separation is an
illusion
so our axioms of thoughts those rules of
of thought that we consider self-evident
apply to the world
because it's the same mind that is
behind the world applying those
same axiomatic rules of thinking
but then we use this fact this this
similarity between how
well this equivalence between how we
think and how the world behaves
we use it to our advantage to describe
the behavior of the world
according to these axioms of thought and
that's that's what we call mathematics
we are describing the behavior uh of the
world
and what it i think ultimately informs
us of
is of how mind behaves that's what
mathematics is telling us
a mind has some inherent
patterns of behavior which a jungian
would call
archetypes of behavior unions went as
far as to say that
the axioms of mathematics were
archetypal in nature marie louise von
france
wrote a book i think in 1974.
i think it's called the number and time
i'm not sure anymore about the title but
they explore this notion to which i
subscribe
the archetypes of minds are the
um how to say like they're the
fundamental source codes
that's one way to put it another way to
put it would be to use
a vibration analogy you know when you
pluck a guitar string
it vibrates according to one of its
normal modes of vibration
it plays certain notes but not other and
that note depends on how long the string
is
the elasticity of the string so mind has
its normal modes of excitation once mind
gets excited it
gets excited in certain ways and not in
others
so there are this archetypal
fundamental modes of behavior in mind
and i think mathematics by giving people
direct
inner access to those templates allows
us to describe
from the outside as well how the world
behaves and it gives
us profound hints to what mind is
and how it comports itself interesting
so
there to so it's more accurate to say a
bottom-up pan psychism
given what cosmopsism currently
describes itself as
but if you could say more accurate i
would say
top-down pencils it's a top-down pan
psychism yeah
oh interesting from from mind from from
a universal mind from your individual
mind as opposed to
to from microscopic minds to us to uh
okay
oh interesting okay interesting so a top
down
pan psychism from universal mind to us
and but there
there's a there is some interesting so
the
the feedback sort of function isn't
necessarily from an at like an abstract
mathematics that are happening
beyond the like quantum field level
and then and they're going through this
process of the
uh unfolding and unfolding as like david
rome would say
but but it could or from this universal
uh consciousness level or this infinite
consciousness level
so it could you the idea is that it
could be doing the
on the unfolding and folding from an
th those seem like the same thing to me
as well this
in that macro micro sensor yeah go ahead
go ahead i see how you're visualizing it
because the laws of quantum mechanics
are microscopic
laws you're thinking in terms of the
bottom
up um i understand that
um i think the way to visualize
space um is is
misleading um when you go down that path
the laws of quantum mechanics apply to
all space everywhere
yeah these are fundamental laws um
in modern physics we even don't talk
anymore about literal particles we talk
about excitations of a field
particles are little ripples on a field
like ripples in the water there's
nothing to the ripple but the water in
the same way there's nothing to a
particle but this
feud today we still didn't manage to
reconcile
the different quantum fields so we still
talk about a set of them
but there is a very strong intuition in
physics that
they are actually all facets of one
field
and this one field is not spatially
bound
it doesn't have a size it it it is the
entire universe
i i was about to say it encompasses the
entire universe
it is the entire universe um and the
laws apply to this spatially unbound
field
so even if you talk about microscopic
laws a term that we use because
we are not able to separate
uh and bring these laws into focus on
micro
macroscopic objects they are hidden
behind their
own interactions so to see them we need
to look at the micro
microscopic system but but this is an
artifact
of our ability to detect something
that something in itself is not
microscopic it is the behavior the
template of movement or vibration the
archetypes
of a spatially unbound quantum field
which
is the universe the laws of quantum
mechanics are not even
local so um when we talk about
microscopic laws we are just saying that
we can't discern these laws unless we
look
at very tiny things it doesn't mean that
the laws are only
in the tiny things no they are in front
of you right now they are making this
screen in front of you
be able to exist and do what it does
it's just that we can't discern them at
the microscopic level
but the laws are not microscopic they
are universal
yeah okay this is a very interesting way
so like uh like an
implicat or like a source code or an
infinite consciousness or cosmic
consciousness that
it would it it pervades absolutely
everything
always and that it's not um
but this this part of it's this part of
it's interesting you mentioned this
um there is a sort of potentially
power law of the most
common um um abstract mathematics
the relationships that are going on and
that
those most common relationships
emerge in the holographic illusory
space-time
as the most common archetypes uh
yeah go ahead yes uh okay now you hint
that uh one of the most difficult topics
in science and philosophy today
um we do not have consensus about
how the laws of quantum mechanics
which we discern at a microscopic level
how
they somehow give rise to
the classical laws of physics like
maxwell equations newton's equations
why do these equations approximate
so well the behavior of of the world we
see
and how do they emerge from a purely
probabilistic
framework which which is what seems to
apply at the most fundamental level now
on purpose avoiding the word microscopic
i'll talk about the most fundamental
level
how does the orderliness of
macroscopic laws arise or emerge
out of the probabilistic behavior of
nature
at its most fundamental levels we do not
have a clear answer to that there are
many attempted answers
uh i'm right now reading an excellent
paper
by a member of the austrian academy of
sciences the leader of a
quantum physics group in the university
of vienna which i think is one of the
most
promising avenues of investigation now
we have a
cubism which is another attempt to make
sense of this
but it's an open question somehow that
probabilistic behavior at the most
fundamental level
preferentially leads to the emergence
of recognizable regularities which we
call
laws of nature
and then that leads
us into recognizable phenomenological
states so then there's that relationship
so so in a sense
we can say that there are
specific there's a feedback
mechanism that occurs where the more
that i
as my illusory individual
become more causeless joy and
imperturbable peace the
more that i become that the more that i
cause a feedback loop to this
source code that then makes the abstract
mathematical relationships more in the
emergent direction
of that causeless piece causes joy in
imperturbable peace
we do not know if and how these feedback
mechanisms
work we haven't been able to to model
them but i think it would be
extraordinary
implausible to say that the direction of
influences here
is only in one way points only in one
way i think it's extraordinarily
impossible i think it's
almost a virtual certainty that there
are
feedback mechanisms in operation here as
well
because we've known from complexity
sciences for instance
that it is feedback mechanisms that give
rise to complexity
and boy is this world complex so there
there should be
feedback mechanisms mechanisms operating
at every level here including
endogenous experiential states
that are providing feedback mechanisms
in a way that we we haven't been being
able to model and discern clearly yet
and we could say that then that feedback
is potentially the idea of the
co-creators
that we are these
we have a co-creative relationship with
reality this is an extraordinarily
sensitive topic
so it's so easy to be misunderstood to
be misunderstood when you talk about
this so
bear with me um there is an approach in
physics a very conservative
very level-headed i would say
unassailable
approach for interpreting quantum
mechanics i would say it's not even an
interpretation
it's an acknowledgement of what quantum
mechanics is saying
which is called relational quantum
mechanics by an italian physicist called
carlo rovelli who has written a number
of
very good books and what ravelli says
is that you know if you bite the bullet
of quantum mechanics from experiments
then there is no physical quantity no
physical
entity that's absolute they're all
relative everything that's physical is
relative to to an observer is relative
to a point of measurement
which then immediately raises the
question well if everything physical is
relative
then is it relative to what whatever
it's relative
to it can't be physical otherwise you're
getting to infinite regress
right so um if you
understand this you will immediately
come to the conclusion that what is
really out there is not physical it is
mental
and physicality is relative to mentality
yeah and that's how physical it arrives
from an interaction between two segments
of mind at least two
um physicality is relative to mentality
that's what quantum mechanics seems to
be
suggesting and the mentality part i
added because i think it's inevitable
it's the only other thing we know of
next to physicality
but quantum mechanics seems to be
telling us quite unambiguously
especially after a superb experiment in
2018 that sort of closed our loopholes
that physicality is relative and then
relative to what i would say it's
relative to mentality
so in so far as each person
is a observer a different observer with
a unique perspective
then your physical world is
fundamentally different from my physical
world
because my physical world is relative to
me and i'm taking a different
perspective
so we all inhabit different physical
worlds and more physical world
bear with me don't misunderstand me yet
i have to complete this thought
so of course we co-create
our physical world because it's relative
it arises from an interaction between
our personal dissociated mentation
and the transpersonal mental states out
there it is from that interaction
that our physical world is created so we
co-create it we are half of the equation
however we describe our respective
physical worlds in mutually consistent
manners you also would say well there is
a moon at night there are stars there
are trees there are cars
you know what i mean um so the other
part of the equation
seems to be transpersonal mental states
in which we are all
immersed can we change that i would say
all indications are that are that we
can't
because otherwise i would just conjure
up the world to be much better than it
is
now and i seem to be unable to do that i
don't seem
to be able to create my own reality
fully
and i understand that that's not what we
are claiming either you're not saying
that we all create our own reality
you're saying that there is some degree
of influence
so i would say there's a massive degree
of influence as far
as the physicality that surrounds you is
concerned
but what ensures that your physical
world is consistent with mine and with
everybody else's
is this transpersonal ocean of mentation
that is out there
and then can we as individuals influence
that
ocean of transpersonation
i personally think very little if at all
some of the greatest minds of all time
have influenced that and made
everything much better i i
am open to that idea but then you could
say well
i influenced the world in trivial ways
like um if i
use my arms and i move a rock i've
influenced the world
but what you mean is is something deeper
than that
i mean i mean michelangelo you know that
yeah okay
yeah i'll go along with that but that's
not what we mean
right what we mean is can your inner
attitude
influence the physical world through
non-physical means in other words
not through the use of perception and
everything that correlates with
perception
can a thought can a inner feeling
influence something known locally
perhaps
there is some evidence that this could
be the case
arising from research on so-called psi
phenomena for instance
at the university of virginia in the u.s
but i i'm tempted to think that that
influence is
rather limited let me give you another
example on that is even something as
simple as like if we have the spectrum
from you know michelangelo to something
very simple
it can be something along the lines of
when you are with another person
especially if it's a family member or a
friend
um the idea is that everything is
inextricably connected in this knot of
life
and that if one has
that equanimity that
immovable peace that causes joy just by
that
simple phenomenological state
can significantly affect
what the other person's experience is
and
so that slowly in a sense um
it it takes the suffering out of the nod
of life
how is that how does it take the
suffering out because
by your phenomenological state being
that
causes joy and imperturbable peace it
butterfly effects
to the other per yeah in that in that
nod of life
all of a sudden the other person feels
your
peace and then
they themselves also take the notch down
and we all
know of the scenario where you if you go
a notch up they go a notch up and it
just
versus bringing it you see you slowly
work
out the misery and the suffering and the
needless
um replaying of the worst
possible uh archetypal
uh phenomenologies yeah
i this this section has been super
super interesting um in this last bit
is it is it possible to say that the
like there is wherever everywhere
is this source code implicate cosmic
consciousness infinite consciousness
it's non-spatial
non-spatial everywhere or nowhere yeah
yeah yes
okay so we have this non-spatial um
god it's everywhere um
yeah we're nowhere so so now this idea
that
from
this source code implica etc
from there we we have a
we have a we have a power law of
the abstract mathematical possibilities
that exist and then from there it's
possible
that there is the emergence of
phenomenological states
and that we have a direct feedback
potentially
influence on that
that on those abstract mathematical
states by in in a sense we can drive
the not of life anywhere from a simple
relationship making it better
to being like a michelangelo or an elon
musk and trying to drive some sort of
massive artistic or technological
revolutionary change to better the world
well look um
i think what you're hinting at is is our
does our influence extend beyond the
visual or perceptual cues that we
provide i mean
you have that you had that example where
of
a discussion that escalates um you could
say well it escalates because each
participant is providing obvious visual
cues to the other he's speaking louder
his eyes are going wide open he's
gesticulating more
um but what you're hinting at if i
understand you is that
beyond the perceptual cues beyond your
physical action
in the world there is a direct influence
between your inner states
and the inner states of other people and
maybe the inner states of the universe
at large
it's beyond the visual cues um so that's
correct i see you're nodding so that my
interpretation and you call that a
transpersonal
ocean well um
in so far as there is a direct influence
between you and something outside you
it's going through a transpersonal
field of field ocean yeah i like that
yeah yeah the drop in the ocean analogy
yeah an ocean a few
these are all metaphors you get my
meaning
um can that be happening
i think it can it's a personal opinion
i think people who deny that that's
happening um
are in a position to deny it because
usually that happens together without
the visual cues
and and and physical effects that we
produce just by being
in the world with this you know just by
existing we displace air we occupy a
certain volume in space
so because these things always go
together
the so-called trivial influences which
are visual perceptual cues and your
physical presence in the world
and the direct marsupial influences it's
very hard to
tease them apart so you can
categorically say that there are these
more subtle influences
as well that's why it's so difficult to
categorically say yes they exist because
it's difficult to tease them apart from
all the other things that are happening
i think there is some research
indicating that these subtle
influences do occur
but they are not massive because if they
were massive
i mean give you an example if i knew
that war is about to happen i would
immediately see it meditate concentrate
and stop it from happening but
i can't do that i can't stop world
hunger hunger i can't i can't stop
the devastation of the environment that
is happening around the world today i
can't stop people from getting sick i
can't stop my loved ones from dying from
cancer and heart attacks
so somehow
the so-called physical way of
influencing which does not entail a
direct
uh inner connection but just your action
in the space-time framework that we call
the physical world
those seem to be overwhelming in
relation to the more
subtle channels for for influencing
things i think
it's just an observation it's not even
an opinion it's an observation
um and that's what makes it difficult
to categorically pin down this other
thing that might be going on
and the thing is if it is going on then
it opens up a whole
lot of other degrees of freedom yeah so
it's important to know whether they are
actually going on or not
it it it almost seems like a fool's
errand to try and say that it doesn't
go on in the sense that if
if if the even the the simple
beautiful imaginative idea of a
rock star electric car company that you
know may take
two decades to actually get into solid
production worldwide
does end up that started just as that an
imaginative idea
now is able to distribute tens of
thousands and more
of these um of what would
what one could call the top quality
electric um vehicle across
across the planet which then somebody
else does
in a sense exchange that
value of of money you know for the the
vehicle and
so then they themselves they've
basically taken what was an
an imaginaid imagine that imagined idea
that they themselves are now purchasing
and now it's in there
it's even something that they use every
day um
and so yeah and that same thing is true
about
basically everything and steve jobs was
one of the ones that said that you know
these
devices the phones and computers and but
everything else as well
were literally imagined by people and
executed by people
that are just like you and so that's why
the idea is
you know there is of course a bell curve
and there are people that are extremely
conscientious um and that are
that can abstractly reason and that have
emotional intelligence to work with
teams and stuff like that versus other
people that don't but there's all these
mixes in between
and and so people have the possibility
to make things
even incrementally better even at that
at that person level
and in a sense bernardo i i want to ask
you this
question as well are you from you're
familiar with
cloud shannon and of course
and yeah and so the you know the idea
that
we've been talking about kind of like
what would be a hypothesis in some ways
of
what his work an extrapolated
potentially version of his work would be
i have a way to
to ask you about that process
is it the same way to envision
a zygote and the way that a zygote
becomes
an adult and the same way that a
seed becomes a tree
and the same way that a big bang becomes
a civilization
and there is that compact information
theoretical substrate that
does that process and then there's and
then is there
would you say a recursive function
as well in all of those processes
so you're alluding to shannon's
information theory
and communication theory
shannon was basically trying to model um
what colloquially you can refer to as
the amount of information
that is transmitted given a transmitted
receiver and a channel that has noise
and he modeled all that
um the information that is transmitted
is inherent
in the transmitter so it's not created
out of you know out of nowhere
so if i understand your line of thinking
you're thinking about the information
being implicit in that
implicate order to use it as a metaphor
based on the word
the work of david baum
and that information is just unfolding
and becoming
visible exfoliating as an acorn grows
into an oak
or as the big bank grows into a
civilization am i interpreting it
correctly
yeah whether that information
well i i would say it it is an
implication of determinism
problem is determinism is not doesn't
hold quite well at the
at the quantum level
i would say that almost by definition
whatever
is whatever happens whatever unfolds
is the realization of an implicit
implicit potential of the universe
almost by definition because if it's
happening it was a potential before
otherwise it
it couldn't happen right
so there is a
at least theoretically there is
a plenum a a a
level in the hierarchy of existence
where you could say that everything that
has been is or will
ever be already is as a
potential and then and then what we are
interested in is is how that potential
unfolds and becomes a reality
or what are the influences of that
process can we guide it can we steer it
in a certain way
it's a valid question at the same time
it's an extraordinarily
complex question it may be
well it almost certainly is beyond human
cognitive abilities today i think
well in a sense
the way that you can take a a zygote and
that you can begin
screening the embryos and
be able to to take even maybe multiple
embryos and you know this is you know
there's some bioethics implications that
that occur here
but to be able to screen many embryos
and then to be able to identify ones
that potentially have single or multiple
point mutations that are causing
downstream
illnesses and say that you know
let's not uh continue the evolutionary
process of that
but actually these that have a more
that have better health outcomes but
also that we can you know
it is in a sense an a t c and g in a
double helix that can then be
reprogrammed
as long as you know we do this uh
longitudinally and figure out the right
combinatorics for the right
outcomes um that
we're doing an interventional process
that has these downstream effects so
in that analogy it would be the same way
that you can tweak
zygotes embryos and is in the same way
can tweak the existing um
uh making the model t a hundred years
ago
and then having the motor vehicles
begin spreading around the world or or
now there's a hundred thousand or more
commercial flights that happen every
single day across the planet
from the idea of like we want to do that
thing called flying
and so there there is a
there's a way to affect you know like
john von neumann would
would call it like this strip in a sense
and like
you are in a sense making a mutation
in the strip and that mutation
that you make to enable humans to fly
across the planet
for every you know uh iteration
of of human that exists downstream is
going to have the airplane
present um for them to to enjoy
look the history of science is the
history of
uh manipulating possibilities
and putting things to work uh in a way
you want them to work for you
using the laws of nature in your favor
technology is basically applied science
science is about figuring out what are
the patterns of evolution i'm using the
word evolution here in a
broad sense not necessarily darwinian
evolution alone
but in the sense of dynamisms things
happen things are dynamic they unfold
and therefore we can say that they
evolve
um and the history of science is the
history of figuring out how this
evolution happens
and then putting it to use for us like
creating a model t
and now you know shooting humans to the
moon on the top of a big rocket
um did this
improve our lives from a certain
perspective undoubtedly uh really we
live longer more comfortably
we have the means to do things today
that previous generations wouldn't even
dream of of course there are enormous
ethical implications for
further increases in this power you know
we stole the fire from the gods
uh we took the realm of uh evolution on
earth
and in all senses even in the darvinian
sense we have taken the realm now for
how species evolve which species will
die which species
will live we decide we've decided that
for instance wheat would be the most
successful grass on the planet
we've decided it we've decided that cows
would be one of the most successful
mammal mammals in the world now of
course from point of view of the cow
that's terrible because they're being
killed and tortured like pigs and
chickens
every day but from a darvinian
evolutionary perspective
uh they are on top of the world there
are more cows now than
many many many many more than has ever
been in the history of this planet
so we've taken the realms whether we
like it or not whether we like it or not
it's our decisions that will
decide whether most of the species in
the world today will go extinct or not
it's our decisions that will define
whether we survive
one more century uh or not so whether we
like it or not you know we've stolen the
fire from the
the fire from the gods and how to use
this power correctly uh
is is a whole discipline in itself it's
it's
ethics how far can we go
in manipulating in nature which is
basically everything and manipulating
everything
um when should we stop and say well
we have the power to manipulate it but
we haven't yet acquired
a sufficient understanding of what we
are doing
in order to manipulate it responsibly
should you use the power you have
um for the mere fact that you have that
power
or should you enforce uh some matter
rules on yourself and say well
i have the power to change it but i'm
not sure exactly what i'm doing
so i will not use it i mean um
to give you an i'm i'm a member of the
computer retro community um i like to
fool around and change with this old
computers
if you would give a computer to a kid
the kid has the power to press every
key to press different buttons connect
and disconnect
things but chances are that you will zap
the computer
if you do that so the kid has the power
to do that should the kid use that power
until the kid
understands what a computer is how it
works how it's supposed to be used
so uh one could say the same thing about
the
operating system of the human body as
well absolutely
absolutely and we are messing around
with it uh in in all kinds of unexamined
ways
for instance we mess with our operating
system just by watching television
and we mess it in a very bad way just by
watching television
of all things by choosing where you
breathe your air
you're messing with your operating
system by choosing what thoughts you
think
and there is nothing new age about it we
know that mind and body are
deeply interconnected in surprising ways
but
by allowing certain thoughts to go
unchecked
you are influencing your operating
system the thing is when it comes to our
to our own body we don't have a choice
because choosing not to influence it
is in fact to influence it in an
unexamined way
we we don't have a choice there right we
better get our act together
because whether we want it or not we we
will be influencing it
but the mere fact that we are living
that we are going about life
other things are not necessarily like
that um
so i i don't have the the ethical
ethical answers
to this um i'm not an ethicist um
as a technologist i have
the intuit not intuitive the instinctual
tendency
to err by doing more than i should
because i'm a technologist
and if i see that protean power in my
hands
the fire of the gods in my hands i have
an instinctive urge
to go and check and what can i do with
this to press the buttons even if i
don't understand the buttons
but there is my id you know my freudian
id
the supervisor in my mind who's saying
hey wait a moment
don't give in to all of your instinctual
instinctive urges
because there are more things at play
here that's about as much as i can say
about this
if it feels like a lot of that has to do
with
what has been quoted as this pause the
pause
that is what enables us to
be observant rather than reactive
and that pause when unlocked
the promethean fire um to
pause and to observe and to
compute the combinatorial longitudinal
effects
take stock before you start messing
about with things right
i would i would say that look there are
certain problems we face today that
where we no longer have the luxury to
pause and contemplate we have to act
even if we don't know exactly what we're
doing
for instance um if i
take climate science seriously which i
do
i think we are no longer in the luxury
position of
pausing and oh let's see how this goes
for all we know it's already too late
that the fact that we don't know it is
already an urge for action and i would
be
willing to endorse nobody's waiting for
my endorsement but
for from my in my own mind i would be
willing to endorse
people would say hey let's develop some
technology to actively try to compensate
for the climate effects that we are
causing
let us i don't know let's blanket this
sahara or no no white
sheep in a sense it's so simple in the
sense of just transitions
uh intelligently uh from
the use of hydrocarbons uh to nuclear
fusion
and all these other extremely uh
futuristic
star trekian styles of energy and
complete abundance for all and
for use the mass energy equivalents
to make replicators and
synthesize whatever you would like from
pure energy um
and this
it really is in a sense going like
like what
do you want for your great grandkids
in 100 years you know you want this
absolute flourishing prosperous society
for them and for
all and so the question then is how do
we make that those incremental
architectural steps and
and why not galvanize the world
like one of the problems that eric
weinstein talks a lot about is just that
what's going on with our like
sense-making apparatus around
allocating the brilliant minds with the
proper incentive structures
to things like the sdgs we know
that solving these things like the sdgs
is exactly one of the biggest
longitudinal
um success points that we want to have
yeah you touched on a number of things
that
that are my buttons so
very me look the first thing is
for as long as our mainstream metaphysic
metaphysics is materialism
people will not move to
better the world for four generations in
the future
because you know their grandchildren
will be dead by then they will not get
to know their great grandchildren and
they will be dead
and under materialism they will cease to
exist so it is all
quote immaterial what will happen four
generations from now and that's a big
problem of materialism because it
sort of stimulates this short-term
pillaging mentality
which is very dangerous but under
idealism
hey your great-grandchildren are you in
another form so is a planet
so are the birds yeah yeah no so you you
have any
you have a stake you're invested in this
yes yes um
now having said that the problem of
energy that you touched upon and this
futuristic
energy sources energy is the key
because you see we can solve everything
else if energy is for free and abundant
everywhere
we can desalinate ocean water and have
potable
water anywhere in the world at the drop
of a hat
and solve the freshwater crisis which is
one of the biggest
looming crisis in the world today
recycling you know what the main problem
of recycling is is that it's a
major energy drain to recycle things you
need to heat them up you need to
reprocess them it consumes a lot of
energy
but if we could have energy for free
everywhere we could recycle
everything everything another one the
food crisis
hey vertical farms would solve the food
crisis what's the problem
yeah you cannot count on sunlight
because sunlight only hits the top layer
the layers underneath are in the shade
food doesn't grow but you can put
artificial lighting yeah you can put
leds and you can grow things 24 hours a
day
in urban areas to fill the entire
populations why don't we do that
because it takes energy and energy
is not available everywhere now the
reason we got away
from the magical abundant forever source
of energy which is nuclear energy
is that it's unsafe and it produces
waste uh
that is the risks of stor of storing
that are just unacceptable
but we think of nuclear energy in terms
of the 1950s
when reactors needed what we call active
safety
in other words if everything shuts down
then the reactor explodes
if you put a plug on everything the
reactor explodes because it needs to be
actively controlled it's active safety
since then we have passive safety
nuclear reactors thorium reactors wave
front reactors this technology exists
and these reactors are such that if
anything goes wrong
the whole thing shuts down no i mean if
if you pull the plug the whole thing
just shuts down the reactor doesn't
react the reaction doesn't continue
unless you're
constantly stimulating it in just the
right way
if fukushima had happened and that was a
passive safety reaction of reactor
nothing would have happened the whole
thing would have just a boom shut down
with that wave
but that's fission and we have fusion
tokemax stellarator
that's even better yeah that's even
better but it doesn't exist today and
that's the galvanization of resources
and talent
um to tackle that yeah yeah but
i'm insisting on this because passive
safety reaction reactors
exist but the laws forbid us from doing
more r d and deploying them
now imagine for a moment that we could
deploy them these are reactors that
use as fuel spent
fuel from old generation reactors so you
would clean up the earth
by using them if we would deploy them
and have the courage to understand that
the technology has changed
we could deploy them everywhere and we
would solve nearly every problem we
could recycle everything we could grow
vertical food farms everywhere
desalinate ocean water
i mean the world would be different not
to mention the fact that would pollute a
lot less because these reactors
uh produce no airborne pollutants
anyway this was my pet subject
i'm so happy yeah i'm so happy you did
that
you're like there were so many of my
buttons pushed there i must
get this all out i love that yeah um
i want to ask about
if we observe
the the observers
that is this now
the notion that there are
a
an infinite amount of observers
and that there is a
there is a
a dimensionless singularity that is
indivisible and undescribable and that
there are all of these potential
infinite observers and that
there is an evolutionary process that is
occurring in all of those
and we can even just focus it in on this
one but i am curious of what you think
about those
about that other idea it's almost like
that the
that the the the function is to
[Music]
validate the infinity
like and that's why the
infinite observers occur and then
there's that evolutionary process and
then
the idea is that the telos telos of
this evolutionary process
potentially baked right in there in the
initial source code like we were talking
about earlier
is that telos ii
[Music]
oroboros is the telos
for the recursion or the the quine
um what what is the that tilo so it's
both that
that that infinite consciousness
multiversal perspective plus the
italic perspective i i think you hinted
on at the answer already
and and i think you know you did i would
just agree with you
um just
on the terminology um i think there are
infinite perspectives but one observer
like schopenhauer said
one eye of the world that looks out from
every creature
what is different is the perspective
what goes in your visual field in each
instance
but the eye is the same the subject is
the same i think
the subject in you is the same subject
amy if we would become a music
in an ideal sensor deprivation chamber
together
what it's like to be you would be
identical to what it's like to be me
and we would basically be identical what
changes is the perspective
but it's okay to talk about multiple or
infinite observers because that's how
physics defines the observer
it defines it in terms of the
perspective but philosophically i would
say
the core subjectivity of every observer
is the same so there is actually only
one
server yes that is that is then in a
sense
you could you could say um fractaled out
yeah
yeah yeah you can you can immediately
get intuition about it by closing one of
your eyes
and then you know two perspectives the
same observer
that's interesting that's interesting
yeah
and if you put your finger in front of
your nose and you look with one eye and
look with the other you see that the
part of your finger that you see with
one eye and the other is completely
different
yeah so there isn't even a part of the
finger that is common to the two
perspectives but the observer is the
same
examples very interesting even at the
child level can begin
getting that stuff the only difference
is that
in the case of what's happening here uh
the two perspectives are separated
but they are conscious in time or at
least
they seem to be i have a friend
professor bernard carr who was
first student of stephen hawkins i'm not
sure i should
publicly say this but not that i started
a sorry bernard if
i if i if i said too much
he's working on a theory of time a
multi-dimensional theory of time
that may explain why or how
one subject can be many and my personal
intuition about it not necessarily what
he's saying
i don't know what he's going to say but
my personal intuition about it
is that we are the same subject in
different timelines interacting with it
with
itself across those timelines if that is
conceivable at all
yeah um so where is this all leading
right yes where is that
acorn how would the oak look like
um i am an empiricist as well
so i take my cues from what i see
happening and if you look at the
evolution of life
which is the apex of cosmic evolution as
far as we
are aware of when you look at how life
is evolving and what is the apex of that
there is a very important sense in which
we are the apex
in the sense that we have become for
good or worse the dominant species on
this planet
what is it that has allowed us to occupy
this position what is the unique
cognitive ability of our consciousness
as humans that has differentiated us
from everything else alive in the world
today and arguably everything else that
has
ever been alive on this planet in the in
the last
three and a half billion years of the
history of life
i would say it's metacognition it's our
ability to not only experience
things but to know that we
experience things is the ability to say
i am having this thought as opposed to
just having the thought it's ability
it's the ability to say
i am the one having this feeling
as opposed to just having the feeling um
when my cat
is eager to go out in the morning
my cat feels the eagerness it's an
experiential
state but i think from from my cat's
perspective
he is the eagerness my cat i don't think
has the ability to step out of itself
and say
i am the subject feeling eagerness
i am not the eagerness i am the one
having the eagerness
um douglas hofstadt called this
stepping out of the system in his
monumental and magnificent book godo
aschebar
we have this ability to step out of
ourselves step out of the system
and then contemplate the system from the
outside and the system is us
but we have this ability to metacognize
not only cognize
but to cognize the cognition in other
words metacognize
so insofar as we are the apex of the
evolutionary trajectory
and what defines us as consciousnesses
is meta consciousness in other words
conscious metacognition self-reflection
self-awareness
then i would say the whole of nature
seems to be
pushing towards this ability to
metacognize to self-reflection
self-awareness to the ability to not
only feel but to step
out of the feeling and say i am the one
having the feeling
and maybe beyond us nature is
instinctual
and it's overwhelmed by the flow of its
own
instincts which probably is not very
pleasant um it's very probably very
confusing
very stressful um or perhaps
fantastic as well in other ways i don't
know
but it it's not able to step out of
itself and contemplate
contemplate itself in the way we can do
that so perhaps
it is doing that through us perhaps we
are
those eyes that turn back and looked
back at the
at existence and said oh this is what's
happening
this is what's going on maybe the this
is this
universal metacognition conscious
metacognition
and we are just the beginning i don't
know
yes this is
where i could also include
some of the existing technological
advances that
have enabled us to feel
even more like we are getting a mirror
of
the nature of reality and those advances
are things like artificial intelligence
they're like virtual realities um
simulation technologies
yeah so then that question is that is it
then
or oroboros and recursive is the
is the tree dropping the seed for
another tree
metacognition is the ability to turn
your cognition
towards itself it is the aura bars there
is no better symbol there is no
connection
yeah it's it's when you stop looking out
and you turn to yourself and say oh
this is what i'm feeling this is what
i'm thinking that is the auroboros
this is auroboric that's super
interesting and
so the relaxation of the awareness um
into the simultaneous uh
individual universal transcendent the
feeling of truth
when you relax the awareness inward is
the
epitome of the auroboros but then yes
on the on the i like that a lot and then
on this
on the trajectory of where it seems like
an automata
uh orthogenesis is what it kind of
seems and feels growing towards right
yes so look back at itself
and yes yes there and then there's that
oroboric moment like you just described
but then there's another
like whatever ends up happening with the
synthesis of
ai vr simulation technology
wherever that ends up going there's the
transcension hypothesis
of going john smart of going
inward and that kind of solving like the
fermi paradox and stuff like that of
just
the oroboric moment of of going into
infinite designer virtual worlds and
just going into the next
the inner world which is the outer world
yes yes yes um
this is rich territory um i think this
is a fascinating subject
to go back to technology do you know the
oculus quest that's virtual reality
do you have one i've played with that
yeah okay
i own one um and there is something
everybody can relate to without a
psychedelic trip just by
using that of course the psychedelic
trip brings the same insight a thousand
fold stronger
but if you use the oculus quest for half
an hour
you become so immersed in that you take
it so much for granted
as reality as the world where you are in
that when you take it out and you
realize oh
i'm in a completely other world that's
the first thought and then the next
thought is
this too just like that that's the next
start
yeah what makes me believe that
right now it isn't the exact same thing
going on
you have that a lot with psychedelics on
her new trip you have the feeling that
what you're experiencing during the trip
is more real than real
it is so palpably and richly and
unambiguously
real and then you come back and you tell
yourself well that wasn't real right
because after all
what is real is where i am right now and
then you think oh wait a moment
maybe the exact same thing is going on
uh
i can either say that both are real
which is okay
or i can say both are unreal because if
you tell yourself that after that
unambiguous feeling of reality you come
back and you point at it and say oh but
that was not
real then what reason do you have to say
but this is
yeah you see yes um
so yeah i think vr uh mind manipulation
technologies
are going in the way uh of facilitating
this kind of insight
which is ironic right because he would
think you know meditation
and non-dualism you know the eastern
traditions
uh they would not converge with the
madness of our technological society
[Music]
oh man that's probably one of my
favorite
focuses is that grand synthesis
of the yeah non-dual eastern
spiritual perennial wisdom with
what is the rocket ship of what
has happened in since the enlightenment
industrial
revolution towards this uh computers
were just such a massive
um unlocking it it may even be that like
biology has an automata orthogenesis
to create computers um
and an an artificial like we are a
biological bootloader as
elon musk said and i i think that's
quite
fascinating and interesting and then
the the recognition
that the west did create
a serious amount of
of flourishing across there's just
no better thing for you to do when you
have
a like a serious like a femur snaps or
something
than for you to go to um you know like
western medicine medicine
yeah exactly so so there's that and then
there's also like yeah
like a ai is somehow
in vrs and simulations are somehow
synthesizing
with like indigenous and spiritual
wisdoms of the planet
which is super interesting as well
so yeah that's this is such a big
interest of
of it's it's just that whole idea of not
dividing into two and realizing that
it is that it's the same source code
there in the implicate order right so it
shouldn't be surprising that it's
unfolding
going the same directions but somehow
recognize it as surprising
uh look i i am an admirer of eastern
traditions
um no question no questions about that
i'm an admirer of
native american traditions um i'm an
admirer of
african traditions which are i think
unjustifiably um ignored
yeah because the african things with his
heart
and and and that's something we that we
need that color in the rainbow of
humanity uh if you know what i mean
um but i am a
very proud outcome of the western
tradition i don't
pooh-pooh the west at all like many of
us seem to do
um i think the western path
may be misinformed as it may be or
whatever you can say about it i i think
it is a valid path
it's just a path that carries more
responsibility
than everybody else because we have the
prothean
fire in our hands and we can end the
game for everybody
and a drop of a dime so that means that
our responsibility is
greater you can even ask can the earth
afford
the existence of the western tradition
is this not
too big of a gamble because the payoff
is drastic
the payoff may be instant forced
enlightenment 100 years down the road
you know no need for 35 years of
meditation man
just to put this little helmet and there
you are
that's a major payoff but but the risk
is fantastically high um
that said you know i i'm a
proud philosopher in the western
tradition and i think
we poo poo our own tradition too much we
should much we should
honor what is ours we should honor our
inheritance
like uh arthur schofenhauer immanuel
kant
going all the way back to permanentes
how many people know what feminism is so
yeah and how many people
interpret him correctly amongst the ones
that know what he said
i mean 12 scholars in the world
i mean it's ridiculous how much we
ignore
our own tradition while turning our eyes
to the richness of other traditions
which are unquestionable
i think the influence of eastern
traditions in the west has been very
useful very benign
it has given us language a conceptual
tool set that we didn't have
but this should not come at the cost of
our own tradition we are products of the
western world
yeah amen
yeah that's so so well said then there's
there's
always room at the big
buffet of union
this again yoga
does not mean holding a stretching pose
it means
union in sanskrit so please everyone
remember that forever
um and at this big buffet of union
that there are all of these options and
for the for the parent to expose their
child to the options and to follow the
child to follow their curiosity
and for the child to truly
dig the well to water in the sense of
realizing
that infinite consciousness at the same
time
as for them to be able to sample
from that buffet some west
some east some science technology
biotech neurotech vr ai
quantum sciences all the way to
understanding
what the buddhist teaching or or laotz's
teachings confucius's teachings the
african traditions the
um native americans just just there's so
much richness to select from the buffet
in a sense the more exposure also that
you have
at least um to you know become leverage
that pareto
leverage only looking at maybe the five
or ten percent of
all of those that give you the most uh
like 80 or 90
understanding of what the essence of it
is and if you get really efficient at
that process in education
then you become that polymath that is
able to
put on all of these different costumes
to engage with the world and all of
these different ways and
you're you're making novel connections
between fields that nobody else
sees yeah but you know in the process of
doing that
one of those clothes to put on should be
our
own right yes but
let me give you an example um i think
there is a profound point
when um an invited teacher says
thought is your enemy your monkey mind
will just get you caught up caught up in
all kinds of conceptual narratives
and you will completely lose sight of
what is right under your nose
which is who you actually are and what
is actually going on we get so
you know tied up in that conceptual web
so thought is your enemy there is a very
important sense in which this is correct
but you see the west has a tradition
that uses thought to get you out of the
web
peter kingsley calls this
logic through logic as opposed to just
reasoning um he considers true logic
an enchantment it's a it's a way to
enchant your own
mind out of the delusion throw some
fairy dust in your mind in a very subtle
way
you see it and we have a tradition of
people using logic
to do that like um xenos paradox or
paradoxes
you know so you know about it but you
probably recognize that there are many
people who never heard
of xenos paradoxes that's a way to use
logic
to tie you up in such an impossible
conclusion
in inner contradiction that it works
like um
that japanese hype no not a haiku um uh
how is it called again uh it's part of
zen buddhism
uh oh um part of zen
buddhism oh the like the one hand
clapping
yes yes like that yeah yeah yeah yeah so
oh i
forgot what the word is but yeah if i
blanked you blank too i mean this
happened so far
right that's our known local connection
here so
xenos paradoxes work like that and in
modern science we have the tendency to
say well now we figured out the answer
to xenos paradoxes no we
we have the notion of limits and
derivatives and integrals we can make
sense of that
but actually you can't really because
you make sense of that by imagining that
you've reached
a limit that you actually never reach
because it's infinite
it's an infinity so you actually don't
make sense of it you just postpone it
infinitely um and but we we don't follow
that path we say well you know
forget logic forget the thoughts forget
the monkey mind
there is an important sense in which
that's true but it makes us blind to our
own
the richness of our own inheritance our
own
tendencies our own tools uh to get there
and you know i'm making a point of it
because it's one of my you know i have a
beef with it uh
yeah and i like to highlight it every
time i can
you you bring up what is probably
the most um salient and simple
way of endeavoring
as a more thought-provoking human
in our world which is posing
these questions of this true logic
where when you do pose such a question
it makes the other person uh
the com the does not compute um
emotion or or like the mind-blowing
emotion yeah it it
it's inspirational because it it drives
people to
to further inquiry that they
they didn't know that that those things
existed and like you said
there's so much there's so much malware
that is
programmed and yeah and we treat these
things
as mere curiosities like a little game
you play you don't get an answer for it
but then you just dismiss it oh it's
just a little
little game it's not these are tools for
for very deep
uh thinking um but we dismiss them
it's unfortunate yeah and then
rupert spire said there's this
difference between a
something that's not real which is like
the square circle
um or taking the half the distance to
the wall
um yeah that's the xenos paradox of
achilles in the tortoise
yeah yeah achilles never overtakes the
tortoise
you can prove that logically that he can
never overtake the tortoise
it just causes a tilt you know an old
arcade uh
games if you shook the machine too hard
it would tilt
to stop working so zeno's paradoxes just
tilt your logical mind and that's how
they take you out of the story because
you realize that
if you follow the logic very strictly
it's sort of
short circuits it contradicts itself and
then there is a moment that you go like
space is not what i think it is well yes
yeah now you're at us
yes yes got it but then you immediately
come back
and there's these cards that i think are
another very interesting way to do it is
you
you take these you take three of these
little cards
and you put the words uh past present
and future on them
and then you give them to somebody and
you say um
order them as you please and then there
are certain people in the world that put
them
in order of past present future like a
linear order
and then there are other people in the
world that stack all three on top of
each other
and and i think that these are also
those small
in a sense uh like
there's it's like true logic it's also
kind of like um
mind-blowing activities it's it's
questioning
the nature of reality in fun child-like
engaging ways you could even write the
number you know i think
even people like takashi 69 have come up
with interesting things just put
the number six on the sheet of paper and
then you look at it and i look at it and
you see that i see a nine and you see a
six
and it's the same thing with the dress
the dress in 2015
about half yeah half of people saw it as
as black and blue and half people saw it
as gold and white
and um when you when you um there's also
the the necker cube and the reuben vase
um there are all these different ways of
if if you
slowly incrementally
realize that it's not that your
you perceiving the dress as gold and
white is incorrect and me perceiving it
as blue
and black is correct but that both of us
are holding that truth like
that simple recognition so all of these
activities that we've been talking about
are all just
really solid ways to to bring activities
and questions
to adults and children to slowly bring
them towards a more awakened
state yeah i love technology vr surely
yeah yeah i love that i love that
bernardo let's um
let's wrap i have uh one thought
to to wrap with you on um
i've been enjoying oh by the way
everything we were just talking about is
about cleansing the doors of perception
the william blake aldous huxley martha
schopenhauer style of
yeah of cleansing those those doors
um awakening them and okay let's um
let's
let's wrap with this thought
i've been toying around with the idea of
like a
dreamed symphony as a very interesting
analogy for the nature of reality and so
whatever that source or that implicat or
that infinite consciousness
um that that dimensionless singularity
that's
indescribable and indivisible that
that is in manifest
whatever the function may be of
self-determining its infinity whatever
the function
may be um it in a sense we can analogize
what exists right now as a symphony
in the sense that all of us
are artists in the symphony and that
again the idea of the illusory um
individual the the artist just not what
it appears to be
but that we we have this like unique
contribution like
you're going to play the clarinet i'm
going to play the piano someone else is
going to play the sax
and we're even if you play the same
instrument you're still going to play a
different
melody or a different harmony than other
people will
some people are maybe playing a little
bit more out of
tune because they're in like the service
to self
mentality they're still thinking
themselves as
the ego and separate and i mean other
people are in the service to other
they're playing
in tune mentality um so
in our like slowly our like symphonic
evolution has like the
the conductor is like the attractor we
can say in a mathematical system towards
like an
oroboros or whatever the telos is so
how do you like that like dreamed
symphony analogy i think not only is it
an excellent analogy it may be the only
viable analogy um and let me try to tell
you why oh by the way i i would prefer
to say that i am the violin being played
and you
are the cello being played and then i i
like that better
expand on that too more for us
because advice you have a very dual
thing right i am playing the violin as
if the violin were outside of you
uh and then you have to account for that
duality
uh while if i am the violin being played
i am the result of the play
and that's why i'm different of you from
you and you are different from somebody
else we are all unique notes
being produced uh by this underlying
uh instrument um and and that
look the idea of notes appeals to
vibration what is a note it's a
vibration in
air which is produced by the vibration
of a
a string or a hammer or a column of air
in a
in an organ um
and it is crucial to have this as the
metaphor it's the only metaphor i've
found so far because it allows us to
make sense of diversity
if all there is is oneness it's the only
way for you to explain diversity
if you postulate that only oneness is
truly real
because diversity is then the variety of
vibrations or the variety of
excitations of that oneness yes
if look a guitar string can you can
produce different notes with it by
plucking it
with in different ways or by holding
the the chord at different different
points different
holding the string at different points
but there is nothing
to any one of those very different nodes
other than that one string
right the only thing that's going on is
string
any movement but there is nothing to the
note
but the string if you remove the string
there is a note
uh it's like a ripple in water there is
nothing to the ripple but the water
in movement you can't take the ripple
out of the water
you can't do that if you take the water
away there is no ripple
the ripple is the water there is nothing
to the ripple but the water
yet you can have ripples of different
frequencies
patterns of movement heights momentum
direction
i mean that's how you get diversity from
oneness yes
it's the metaphor of vibration so i
think you're right on
wow i love that and i know that uh
sri aurobindo said that the um
the the diversity of the oneness is the
mathematics of the infinite
and yes look even science
is coming well a philosophical part of
science that arguably is not
real science but but it's very
interesting nonetheless m theory the
idea of m theory is that
everything uh all reality
is constituted of patterns of excitation
of a hyperdimensional membrane
or brain as they call it and you can
write all the mathematics for that
so yeah even even physics seems to be
heading in that direction i think it's
an
unavoidable insight patterns of
excitation
and i know this is getting so
interesting i'm so pumped for
for further um explorations here who
else have you heard
talk about the um the dream symphony
because i want to research
them as well
i have a good friend um called uh fred
matzer
he is publishing a book next year he has
a film out called
beyond me and he talks about it but
and i sort of plagiarized him a little
bit because he is the one who said
i am the violin being played yeah yeah
i'm not playing i am being played yeah
yeah
and his idea is that individuals don't
really exist they are illusions
so if they don't really exist they can't
be playing anything because they're not
there to play to begin with
but they may be being played they may be
yeah they may be being played yeah yeah
good and or orobindo also talked about
the body as the
receiving station for universal music
and yeah that's that's another metaphor
right yeah
same metaphor yeah so this is so
interestingly
triangulating on the nature of reality
and i'm so pumped to embed these
beautiful wisdoms that you've been able
to share with
us plus also that you've been
teaching and that are also from all the
leaders because both of us
we stand on the shoulders of such
massive giants
and this this big synthesis
that i'm super pumped and passionate
about is
really the it's
it's the culmination of like the apex of
critical thinking around the nature of
reality and
and it's really really important to use
metaphor it's so important it enables
conversation at the highest levels of
abstraction exactly and
the way you you started the interview
you made you said something in the
beginning
that i didn't react to but i didn't
forget you were saying uh
you know idealism versus materialism
mind versus matter these are all
dualities
yes they are and they ultimately hold no
water
because there is ultimately only one
thing going on the problem is and that's
what you alluded to right now
to get into the discourse we have to
make a concession
to the current rules of the game yeah
so i make a dualist concession when i
label my view
idealism as opposed to materialism and
all the rest
because if you don't do that you don't
get into the conversation
now once you are in the conversation you
can make the conversation implode from
within which is my evil plan
but i have to get into it first
this is such such an interesting way of
viewing it is that there is this
there's this like bell curve that we
could call
like you know somewhere around maybe 95
or so people fit within two standard
deviations and we could call this like
the
evolutionary pacer um where
many people are focused on survival and
reproduction and many of the symbols
that are being exchanged
like memes are of uh kind of that
that that um they're they're not at the
uh the edges of the the bell curve at
these tails
because what's going on at the the
regressive tale
are still some people violence and
slavery
and it's all these bad things but at
this very progressive tale
there are people beyond two standard
deviations that are the ones that are at
the highest levels of abstraction
that have to then create some sort of
stories and metaphors like we gotta do
some
harry potter um pixar walt disney style
communication of the stories to get
um the center the evolutionary pacer for
people to kind of like
level up like we're shooting portals in
a sense for people to jump through
and like you said there has to be
sometimes this
like concession just because you can't
bypass the gatekeeper
unless you do these concessions or maybe
if you embed
the stories in animations or music or
other things but even then like i i
really like
your point we need myths we absolutely
need
the myths otherwise we don't have a
democratic process
so we need modern myths and we need to
take myths seriously
not literally seriously
bernardo wow such a powerful
conversation
thank you for joining us on the show i
had a lot of fun it was a
it was a pleasure i just looked at the
clock now it's been almost two hours i
have no idea
yeah yeah so so fast thank you thank you
and
thanks everybody for tuning in we
greatly greatly appreciate it we would
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about all the subjects that
bernardo was teaching us about
just get going on a more
on a more become a deep
truth drew a deep student of the nature
of reality and
make that if you make that your first
principle you will
be able to have a more happy peaceful
robustly enlightened and successful life
you will be
um at that at that level um so do do
that and inspire more people around the
world today check out the links in the
bio below to bernardo's work
check out his website link that has all
of his essays his books his papers check
that out also his social media links are
there he has a youtube channel he has a
twitter so check that out
and support him support the other people
in your communities that you believe in
begin that process of really mimicking
biomimicking
through inclusive stakeholding of of of
the way that we can
um help fund the people that we believe
in
um so so help help each other out in
that sense
and that's that's all folks thanks so
much bernardo again thank you
thanks for having me boom
we love you very much thanks for tuning
in we'll see you soon
peace
fantastic man
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you